Entrepreneurship is a state
of mind, a different way
of thinking about things.
It's a way of understanding
large challenges
at a conceptual level
and transforming that
into a real solution for a
person, a community, or even
the world.
Entrepreneurs use
technology as a way
to connect people
and create solutions
to problems once thought of
as too big or impossible.
If this sounds like
you, then sign up
and we'll take you through
the Google Design Sprint
process on your original
idea, develop a monetization
strategy, prototype your
product with real users,
develop a marketing
strategy, and master
business skills necessary to
succeed as a tech entrepreneur.
Create, amaze, and change.
That is what this is all about.
Harnessing technology to
create amazing solutions.
So, start your journey
today by enrolling
in Udacity and Google's Tech
Entrepreneurship Nanodegree
program.